GOES TO THE TRIPLE GETS
TRIPPED UP NO THEY SAY PLAY ON
LIFE OF THE CAR AND THAT'S A
FALL. WELL, WALL SHOULD BE
LOOK OUT. THAT CHEESY. AND
THAT IS A WRESTLING MOVE
TAKING DOWN SHREWDER SHREWDER
WAS HOLDING HIM UP AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HE WAS THINKING. HE
ACTUALLY ALMOST BUT INDEED A
BODY SLAM INTRUDER. LOOK AT
THIS. IF THEY THE REVIEW SEE
WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE. AND
RESTORING ORDER AS BOTH
BENCHES SPILL ON TO THE COURT.
A SHOOTER DOES A GOOD JOB
PREVENTING THE LAYUP. BUT I
JUST TOLD ME HE'S HOLDING
RIGHT THERE. SO IT DOESN'T
FALL NOW HE CAN GET SOMETHING
LIKE IT'S IT'S RIDICULOUS EVER
TRANS COMING IN TRES IS COMING
AT THE GARY. TRENT WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF YEAH, BUT THE 3RD
MAN, IAN USUALLY IS A GUY THAT
GETS PANEL SO WE'LL SEE WHO
THEY RULE AS THE 3RD MAN, IAN,
IS THAT GOING TO BE TRUE IS.
OR IS IT GOING TO GARY TRENT.
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS. AND THERE'S A LOT TO
UNPACK HERE WITH THIS REPLAY
AND WHAT JUST WENT DOWN
BETWEEN AND IT'LL BE A SHREWD
OR TENNIS HOT. THIS GARY TRACK
LOOK AT THE TIME IS ALWAYS TRY
TO BREAK TRUST CAME IN, OF
COURSE, TO PROTECT HIS GUY.